hello and welcome to PlayStation Grenade
if you are a PS Plus subscriber in
Europe Australia or New Zealand you may
have received noticed that Sony is
putting 25% on top of the price we
currently paid for the PlayStation Plus
subscription service
I believe Sony is paving the way to
combine PlayStation Plus and PlayStation
now but I'll get to that in a moment
here in the UK the PlayStation Plus
price has shot up from 40 pounds to 50
pounds which is about 65 American
dollars it would have been more but the
ability brexit vote hurts the pound
massively speaking of North America you
guys have already faced a price increase
about 11 months ago and only recently
the offerings on PS Plus have seen
improvements well what do we actually
get for our money let's quickly remind
ourselves before acting like the world
is coming to an end since Sony mimicked
Microsoft's choice to charge players for
online multiplayer
we have progressively been charged more
at present we receive the aforementioned
online play we receive 10 gig of cloud
storage which I personally find very
useful but I know it's not for everyone
we have access to share play where you
can play a friend's game without
actually owning the game yourself and we
also receive discount on the store as
I'm writing this that includes 70% of
Mortal Kombat X 62% of battlefield one
deluxe edition and between 10 and 40
percent of another 78 titles this of
course changes each month and sometimes
each week too if you're one of those
people who buys many games online PS
Plus will save you a huge amount of cash
and put again that's not really for
everyone is it we also receive early
access to demos Vitas and PS Plus extras
while free-to-play titles so in PS Plus
still a great deal well I'll just say it
yes it is especially if you download and
play the PS Plus offerings each month
take July's offerings on ps4 that's you
Game of Thrones and until dawn if we
play those three games then the annual
subscription is already paid for same
again this month Assassin's Creed
freedom cry and Just Cause 3 if we
continue to play the ps3 and Vita
offerings on PS Plus each month then the
price increase shouldn't make any
difference no one wants to give extra
money away and not receive anything in
return so
we shake things up a bit by putting
forward what I believe will happen I
firmly believe PlayStation now on
PlayStation Plus will begin to cross and
eventually become one entity here's the
current issue PlayStation has two
subscription services which are very
similar to one another for anyone who
isn't a hardcore gamer just in case you
don't know what it is PlayStation now is
a streaming service which offers access
to 400 PlayStation games online
and while PlayStation Plus is thriving
PlayStation now is quite suited miss
depending on how you construe the
figures Sony have invested in
advertising how PlayStation now works
seamlessly on PC in a way that suggests
that Sony want PlayStation and PC to Co
inhabit the same ecosystem in a recent
video I posted about the impact of Xbox
one X on PlayStation users there were
many people who said they owned both the
PC and PlayStation I'm depending on
which game they want to flow they will
switch between platforms if these people
represent a larger percentage of the
market then Sony pretty much has the
green light to add streaming content to
PS Plus as their users will take
advantage on both platforms
the real advantage of + are now
combining is the ability to play ps3
games on the ps4 it's not the most
important thing in the world but it
would be great to play Red Dead
Redemption without having to dust off my
ps3 you could take this further back in
time to allowing streaming access to ps1
and ps2 classics instead of the
confusing system in place now in which
we rebuy games for each and every
console PlayStation now has a very mixed
reputation and the service have started
regularly so much so that many of us
have dismissed it completely this could
be the ideal way to improve the service
and keep subscribers happy what do you
think is this a pipe dream or could we
see PlayStation Plus and PlayStation now
combined into one super subscription
service I really would love to know your
thoughts and if you need to vent feel
free to do so below I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade and I'm trying my
best to see the positives in the recent
PS plus price increase oh it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]